the Democrats go out and run save  democracy democracies at stake I think  in this past election that's projection  let's see if they really want to save  democracy if the Republicans are willing  to put their country first past  something like guidelines to dictate to  states that they got to do certain  things like Florida did and Georgia did  to clean up their electoral process I  think that's probably the best service  that they can do for our country and in  the long run it's going to save our  democracy I predict the Democrats will  characterize it as something other than  what it is if the Republicans even do it  and you'll see gridlock because  they have a different parties have a  vested interest in how certain things  are